I'm magazine this week as China's new
face what will Reagan see in a
photograph of a Chinese person and also
a prim that this corner is a little
piece can we see this sterling or it's a
little tip about the top ten America's
newspapers and inside this Time magazine
is a feature story on what time magazine
considers to be the top ten newspapers
we're gonna have a special callin show
on this tomorrow morning at ten o'clock
East Coast time seven o'clock West Coast
time and we want you to if you're
interested go out and get your copy of
this week's time at ease and I think it
to be the best way to go we're gonna
also show you by the way Kevin closest
not here yet and that's where we're
talking about this at this moment we'll
get into that in just a second we're
also going to show you what the top ten
here's what the the spread looks like
what the top ten newspapers according to
Time magazine are and they're in
alphabetical order we could see that Tom
albano do you have it on the character
generator will show our audience what
Time magazine says are the top ten
newspapers the Boston Globe the Chicago
Tribune the Des Moines Register Los
Angeles Times the Miami Herald The New
York Times the Philadelphia Inquirer
st. Petersburg Times The Wall Street
Journal on the Washington Post that's in
alphabetical order and not an order of
preference interestingly enough in this
piece time in many cases when they talk
about a newspaper they dam them with
faint praise for instance they talk
about the Boston Globe and so the globe
transformed into a feisty eccentric
unpredictable paper that wavers from day
to day and even from page to page
between brilliance and and Beth Oz and
in Chicago Tribune they say that they
quote director Neill Koppel on the
University of journalism director Neill
Koppel of the University of Nebraska the
paper is solid but not very exciting the
Des Moines Register the registers
weakness include drab coverage of
culture and lifestyles and grainy
photographs dismal a cluttered section
some dim grainy photographs the Los
Angeles Times
they said The Times 10 years ago when
they did this once before said it gives
the impression of just falling short of
its great potential in some ways it
still does this current article says the
Miami Herald coverage is increasingly
feature --is-- staff members joke that
sometimes they produce jello journalism
with the main point of his story buried
beneath the photographs of scene setting
in the New York Times they say
nonetheless tradition and propriety and
the vast sense of self-importance still
weigh heavily on the Times editors and
reporters as does the constricting
drabness of its first section design and
it goes on the Philadelphia Inquirer at
times Inquirer self-conscious creativity
has led it to shortchange local news as
the associate managing editor Jim
Naughton it used to be said that we
cover Karachi better than the
neighbourhood of Kensington but with the
bulletin gone we are obligated to keep
more of a local record anyway tomorrow a
special hour following Charlene Williams
who is a the immediate past president of
the National Society of black
journalists and she has a local WTOP
radio reporter here she'll be here from
9 to 10 East Coast time and then from
10:00 to 11:00 special callin about this
Time magazine article this week the top
ten America's best newspapers what we'd
like to have you do if you live in one
of those areas is go by Time magazine
today spend what is a month unless you
don't unless you get it dollar 75 read
the article and if you're from Boston or
Chicago or Philadelphia or Miami or in
New York or st. Petersburg in Florida
the Wall Street Journal of course is a
national paper or here in the Washington
area and read these papers give us a
call and tell us whether or not you
agree with the analysis of Time magazine
and I suspect they're people that live
in places like San Jose and where the
mercury is and Sacramento and Milwaukee
and st. Louis and others that make whirl
with the top 10 anyway our guest is here
and he wrote this book called Russia and
the Russians Kevin closes his name is
currently the bureau chief for the
Washington Post in Chicago
and he's here in town visiting and we're
delighted to have him in our studios
good morning mr. close mr. Lam I'm
delighted to be here with the
unflappable Brian let me let me ask you
something in this morning's Philadelphia
Inquirer Saul Friedman seems to do the
most in-depth work about the the trip to
China but he talks here that this is the
only help I can find any other papers
about the comparison between the Chinese
situation in the Russian situation
president briefed on Soviets in Asia
advisors and experts have cautioned the
administration against trying to use the
Soviet threat to prod the Chinese toward
a strategic partnership of the United
States for the Chinese almost as
suspicious of the United States as they
are of the Soviets have sought to remain
independent of the superpower struggles
you spent four years at least in Russia
what what do you think's going on right
now and the Politburo behind the Kremlin
they talking about the president's
Chinese trip I think the Kremlin is
extremely worried about the president's
Chinese trip because you know the
Soviets look across their border they've
got perhaps half a million men on their
arms they have ICBMs targeted on Chinese
targets they've had to split their
strategic forces as a result and they
always have to worry about Chinese
continuous Chinese claims and pressure
against the lambs that that the czars
took from the Chinese in the late 19th
century when when China was very weak
those claims have been unresolved and
they have been a kind of hereditary
sticking point between the two between
the two countries and and the Russians
have the Soviets have no intention of
ever really paying much attention to
those Chinese land claims and they lie
there one of the fundamental
disagreements which exists between -
between the two capitals so when they
see when they see the Americans as
they've been that had to deal with this
American opening to China what's going
on now for more than a decade it's very
disturbing to them even though they even
though they know that the Chinese are
extremely suspicious of u.s. intentions
on the mainland and we've had our we
there's plenty of reason to see that
there's conflict and the
possibility and further of a real
disagreement between the US and China
the Kremlin is not reassured and it's
disturbed by these kinds of visits
particularly from the American leader as
opposed to say a defense the defense
secretary and so forth you were
originally born in Toronto and grew up
in upstate New York and now live in
Chicago mm-hmm
they were the Washington Post since what
70 know what 1967 1967 long time what it
what do you what's the difference of
waking up in Moscow and waking up in
Chicago and going to work every day
what's the mental difference do you feel
any different
I'll say this both places are
exhilarating each each in their own way
Moscow was our original assignment there
was for three years and we extended an
extra year because we found that the
life there was so challenging finding
out fact in a society which is based on
a series of essentially men days
mendacious assumptions both about itself
and and which is dedicated to to to
misleading foreigners about the true
nature of itself that kind of challenge
on a day-in day-out basis as much as
anything just sparked this tremendous
interest in in me and in my family my
wife and our three kids the children
went to Soviet schools for four years
they came back from Russia perfectly
fluent in in Russian and we tried as
much as we could to understand it to
sort of flex into the Soviet into the
Soviet mentality and a Russian
experience that was exhilarating there
was another exhilarating matter and it's
strictly in newspapers or news man's
perspective and that is is that we were
eight hours ahead of Washington time was
so if something broke in Moscow it gave
me the entire day to work on it before I
had to really sit down and started
working at worrying about what the telex
was going to say and when and that was a
very nice advantage in Chicago it's the
other way we're an hour behind behind
you all here so everything has to be
sort of get off earlier
what is exhilarating about Chicago as a
as a person who grew up in the East and
as
like many Easterners and knows Chicago
only vaio hair Airport
arriving there and and settling in there
we found this wonderful city full of
great architecture terrific restaurants
fine music lots of art and very
interesting and open people there and so
we were enjoying it but in a completely
different way from Moscow this morning
in our papers here there's seem to be a
real dichotomy and didn't explain this
from a newspaper man's point of view on
the front page of one of your chief
competitors the New York Times is this
story right here
key afghan area is reported lost by the
guerrillas this is by drew middleton
interestingly enough not kabul as the
the dateline but right here in the
United States obviously wrote either
from western New York yeah quoting State
Department officials and and I think a
one of the international radio stations
okay this is the front page of the New
York Times this story buried in the
Washington Post your paper on page a 13
Kabul radio reports troops take key
Valley as a way of discussing this whole
Afghanistan effort on the part of the
Russians why would one newspaper choose
this as a front page almost a lead and
as a matter of fact you want to see what
another competitor did with it here in
Washington here's what the Washington
Times did they bannered it Soviets
escalate Afghan war yes where would this
story belong on your if you were added
in the front page well since I was in
Moscow and in 79 when the when the
Russians moved into Afghanistan and it
became it had such enormous impact on on
soviet-american relations but also on
Western perceptions of what the Kremlin
was about and in the third world that
had an enormous impact just to back up a
little bit at the time they they moved
in at the time the hundred thousand
troops went to went into Afghanistan
there were constant reassurances by
various sources official on a semi
official and otherwise from the Soviets
this was a kind of temporary action to
bolster this tottering Marxist
government and at the time
I wrote and others of us who were there
at the time wrote that the Soviets are
there to stay that they're not getting
out there will stay if it takes 20 years
they will be in as long as 20 years and
they will not step back they have not
made this commitment lightly and may
lead them to a greater commitment but
they will have to buy the just by the
nature and the logic of the thing they
will have to proceed with it until until
they prevail that's the that's the view
from Moscow in that case well as I see
at the the a13 it seems that there seems
to be a it's it's coupled with a jump
Chernenko said to offer new ideas or is
it no it's an it as a matter fact it's
the only only newspaper we found here
that had this story about the foreign
ministers and in this case and the
defense ministers know I guess they're
all foreign ministers are gonna visit
Moscow and visit Chernenko and talking
about new ideas you know indicating that
there may be an opening here for talks
well there may be it's it would be not
untypical II Soviet too at the same time
they're making a new and harsher
commitment in Afghanistan to also talk
on the other side about well that's what
we're now open to new harm's idea new
talks no Jude yes then that your that
the editor decided that these two belong
together because this is their kind of
you know there's a great split one says
peace one says war you know that would
that would be the way I would play Kevin
closes with us this morning for the next
45 minutes this is his new book when did
you write these got two years off to do
this yes they gave me two years off we
came back in 1981 and I took a leave
from the post which was originally
supposed to be one year and turned into
two because the book took a lot longer
it than I had imagined it's not like
books by a lot of other correspondents
who come back from Moscow and separating
myself from the sort of if I may say so
the conventions of how you talk about
the Soviet Union with an American
audience in mind took a lot longer it
was more of a struggle than I'd imagined
and the book is substantially different
it's completely different from the books
by Bob Kaiser or head room answer Dave
ship or David shipler they all wrote
about Russia they all spent time there
and you said you saw something that
other people didn't see anyone to tell
us about it what is it well what I saw
there and what I felt had not really
been adequately dealt with in American
terms was how a totalitarian police
state actually functioned in individual
terms it I didn't want to talk about
Soviet agriculture I didn't really want
to talk about that the opening of a
Siberia what I thought was fundamental
to the society and governed all other
aspects of life inside the Soviet Union
was this relationship between individual
and the state in a totalitarian system
and that is that is what I really wanted
to capture in the stories that are in
this book
the Russians better off today than they
were 10 years ago materially in some
senses they're better off but there are
many indications that show they're not
while the more Russians have private
apartments than did 10 years ago while
food supplies jet despite seasonal
problems food supplies generally are at
least no worse than they were ten years
ago and so forth there are other
indications which show that life there
is is in fact the conditions of life in
some fashion are deteriorating for
example the lifespan of the Soviet male
has decreased by about two years since
1960 it is the only major industrial
state where this has happened and that
is because in my in my opinion in my
experience there it's in part because
health services which reached a specific
and a particular level in the in the
late 50s when the country was Rhian
spirited because the Khrushchev thaw
death of Stalin the release of millions
from the camps things like that those
kinds of that system of infrastructure
which which has impact on how people
live it kind of peaked and now it is
it's declining the the quality of
medical care and the the kind of the
sort of search and and unrequited search
for us real spiritual values inside the
society which cannot be answered right
now because the ideology inside the
country has
big trouble people don't believe it
anymore the country's a wash and
cynicism and and a lack of kind of moral
commitment to the to the quote gains the
revolution those kinds of things have
brought on an increase in alcoholism
have caused industrial accidents and it
is actually true that in the age group
from 26 to 34 in the Soviet male the the
death rate is so high there that Soviet
demographers have never released the
figures from the 1979 census which show
exactly what that death rate is it's
enough to help shorten the overall life
span of Soviet males that tells us
something profound about conditions of
life inside the country even at the same
time as material conditions are
improving in a in a kind of outward
sense or of a physical sense the reason
in my view the reason there is this this
decline of of commitment and this and
the spreading search for a for a
sustaining spiritual and moral and
ethical values has to do with the
long-term effects of the kind of society
which is which the Soviets have created
there's the this impacted authoritarian
state it's a kind of airless
hermetically sealed sort of psychology
and people in that kind of a situation
seek for something which they can't get
and frequently they can only get it out
of a bottle and so you have these
immense problems they're not redressed
there are great social differences which
have to do with ethnic strains inside
the empire between the [ __ ] millions
down in Central Asia and a great
Russians who run the country a lot of
racism those things are not being
addressed properly and it's these are
all aspects of the kind of totalitarian
society which the Soviets have created
heaven closes with us for another 40
minutes the phones are open and this
morning kind of in depth unusual on the
morning show we're talking about a book
and we're talking about a country and it
just happens to be at a time when which
kind of interesting you look the
parallel here here's what Time magazine
has on its front cover and here's the
book and these two are not really not
separate in any way as in this morning's
against all Friedman wrote a very
interesting piece and the show the
picture get the phone lines will be on
the screen there you folks want to get
your morning paper and get involved here
and some of you who have traveled to
China and Russia probably have some
insight that you'd like to throw into
this pot here's a picture of the
president yesterday over and believe it
says pondering among the palms rest near
Honolulu before leaving for China up
here to regen some are more equal and
saw Friedman The Enquirer Washington's
staff and the knight-ridder Papers run
says Ronald Reagan has spent a political
lifetime crusading against communism in
all its forms now as he heads for a
visit to the Tala Terry and People's
Republic of China the president has
tentatively concluded that well there is
communism and then there is communism he
is as hostile as ever toward the
communism in the Soviet Union which he
has denounced as godless and as the
quote focus of evil in the world and
soviet-american relations are frozen and
fearful distressed Reagan described
China in much the same language a decade
ago calling it a godless inhumane
tyranny but now he calls China a friend
and quote the largest and most important
state in the Pacific Basin well we've I
think we've found for various various
leaders of this country at different
times have found different kinds of
communists that I that I'd like to live
with and I don't like to live with and
this president certainly finds too
Chinese more congenial he's had he's had
you know there's been no contact at the
at the at the top of the at the top of
the two governments in the in rate
during Reagan's administration and that
has an effect on how he looks at the
Soviets I mean he just feels a kind of
cold coldness there an indifference and
in fact the the Soviet Politburo has had
tremendous problems because of the
because of the death of Brezhnev and the
death of on drop off I mean that does
not those events have impact in that
kind of a leadership where they
constantly are at least in the in the
formative stages of any new leadership
they're kind of grappling for power and
the power balance is always up for grabs
and that's kind of a situation so there
it's hard for them to deal with us too
Russians and the Russians this is the
title of Kevin closest book on the
bookshelves of your bookstores right now
if you published by Norton and we'll
take the first phone call the morning
Tulsa Oklahoma good morning how you done
yeah the Tulsa world
I think today I've got three papers is
okay one of the things as you know we're
talking about here is is Russia but the
other thing is China and have you found
anything in any of the three papers I
know there was very little in the USA
Today which we have over here has
nothing on China on the front page it's
mostly local and the Dallas Morning News
says Reagan hopes two or three myths
us-china ties who wrote that piece mid
door yes I really like him I I think
he's been covering the elections deals
and I think really the Dallas Morning
News is about one of the best newspapers
that you can buy I run out morning well
in this interesting enough in this Time
magazine piece the sub cover story they
talk about the Dallas Times Herald in
the Morning News really fighting it out
down there creating two better
newspapers in that case well i if you
don't get done before 8:30 to the two
places where we have them close to us
you'll not get a Valis morning news
that's how how fast and the woman told
me she puts 25 in there every day a lot
of people are are beginning to read it I
was going to ask you guess what you did
it
Rankin kind of confuses me about how he
wants to go to China and he talked so
much about communism and to me communism
this communist I don't care whether it's
a Soviet or whether it's a China and for
him to go to all of this and it seems to
me like it's more election type you're
trying to get us to forget what's going
on in Central America and how many
people don't have jobs and it's kind of
and these pictures
he and mrs. Reagan in their bathing
suits let us see him you know and I
remember four years ago when when he was
saying about Carter signing all these
bills had all these little things in the
rose garden and how is just politics as
usual and I really like a lot of things
that Reagan has done I think he's you
know done a lot of good things but I
hate to see him playing politics is like
the other people have done I really kind
of thought he was above us so I wish
your guests would talk about why you
know the Communists why we don't treat
them both the same
okay thanks Tulse a good job well I
don't think we don't treat him both the
same because the president has has
political goals in mind that have to do
with with I think he he sees and rightly
so
that the Soviet Union is constitutes a
greater threat than China does it's a it
is nearly are equal or perhaps better
than or equal in strategic arms and I
think that's very much on his mind and
he's trying to he's trying to sort of
increase the pressure on the Soviets to
behave in a more conciliatory fashion
both in in Southeast Asia and with
regard to how they deal with us and so I
think he thinks his his his China trip
has that kind of impact next call for
Kevin close Salt Lake City Utah good
morning let me ask you first caller do
you have the either the Deseret News or
the Salt Lake Tribune there all right go
ahead and Belgium is the fourth in
Russia is the fifth in the United States
is the seventh consumer of alcohol as
far as the 68 year old death rate for
males and Soviet Union that was a small
area in the Soviet Union and in the
latest Pravda and Nova
the publication showed that it's
increasingly now is about 72 71 I find I
wish you would get again that would
present a point of view of the Russians
on your news program because Henry cliff
gave a negative narrow point of view we
studied his book found it firstly when I
was there in graduate school and it
showed that there were many years in his
book and many of the comments are
guesses made are totally contrary to
what is published the Soviet press and
also when I spent two years there a
student is also contrary to what I
observed now I like to ask the question
where does your gift it is information
please let me ask you car before we lose
you where do you get your information
besides your two year visit there Fred I
get it from many publications at the
University of California at Berkeley
when I'm down there they have an
excellent Department odd okay thanks for
your call
mister close well the answer is that I I
get a lot of my information from the
same sources in addition to two sources
both in America and in Eastern Europe
and inside the Soviet Union itself which
individuals and non official sources of
information who in fact are have much
greater detail and compelling human
detail about life inside the country
then then you're going to find in in the
Soviet press you know we should say that
the Soviet press as such is it is not it
is an organ of the of the state it is it
is completely under the control of the
party and you know you cannot find in
the Soviet press if a Soviet airliner
falls out of the sky and many people die
that is not reported mine accidents are
not reported railroad trains never
derail in the Soviet Union and ships
don't sink and all those calamities
which are common in the bourgeois West
simply don't exist in the terms of
Soviet news reporting now that I think
is a very fundamental
aspect of of life it's a reality and in
reality is bent because inside the
Soviet Union because they don't have an
interest in in in telling truth about
many things about themselves we said
don't forget tomorrow get your Time
magazine and we're going to talk about
newspapers for a special hour from 10:00
to 11:00 the objective is to get some
reaction to this article and I'm sure
people like who live down in Atlanta may
disagree that the ten top newspapers in
the country does not include the Atlanta
Constitution or the Atlanta Journal I'm
sure a lot of people agree with that
we'd like to hear why the cab County
Georgia go ahead please well the Atlanta
Constitution big story as far as I'm
concerned front page Iran reported
making nuclear bomb and my question
relates to that part of the girls women
women Iran reported making nuclear bomb
yes who wrote it
United Press the essence is that the
Germans are helping in a nuclear power
plant and that will boost the plutonium
which the Iranians are approximately two
years from having their own bomb and
that relates to my question for Kevin
close that has to do with a very cynical
and cowardly type of idea that I have
and that is to trade how valuable is
Afghanistan to the Soviets it is is it
as valuable as Central and Latin America
and even South America and the rest of
the Caribbean to us I say we asked
mister Chernenko Ustinov and Gromyko and
don't bring in that let us have our
Hemisphere and we'll give you will keep
our CIA etc out of Afghanistan we may
even give you Pakistan which is working
on their own nuclear bomb and reportedly
has one and possibly even will let you
have Persia because you would probably
be better for the people of Persia and
better for the world to stabilize that
and to have what's going on over there
so that's a very cynical attitude I have
but what is the alternative what does he
think that the Russian attitude would be
on that Thank You caller by the way that
story I did not find any of the
newspapers here I don't know it but
I haven't read all the UPI dispatches
yet today the comment about Afghanistan
you know the Russian interest in
Afghanistan and in that part of the
world it goes way back it's it's
hereditary it dates back to the Czarist
times and and that's where the Brits the
British played the great game against
against the Russians a hundred and a
hundred and fifty years ago I think it
would be very difficult for us to to to
get mr. Chernenko and the Soviet
Politburo to want a trade when they can
in effect have their cake and eat it too
they they their presence is is is
increasing in Afghanistan they have the
the Marxist government has not fallen it
is a it's a piece of turf in the world
which they've had long-standing
interests in and they're getting deeper
and deeper their hold on it is getting
stronger and stronger I believe at the
same time they're able to cause us
tremendous problems in our own backyard
and put us on the defensive in the
Caribbean so why you know it's as a
Russian was at any Wigan it's not
profitable for them to to you know to
trade the one and the other the reason
the reason they they have to increase
their commitment to Afghanistan has I
think has much less to do with the fact
that there may be American arms or in
some fashion arms from Western powers
flowing to the insurgents than it does
with the the fact that that as they make
even as they make gains resistance grows
as as more and more Afghani has become
involved in the you know in the conflict
as they see that that the way of life
which was there is now really under
under threat and that is not a
Directorate doesn't seem to me to have a
direct relationship to their to the
Soviet presence and gains in Central
America 1977 and 1981 Kevin close spent
four years in Russia as the bureau chief
of the Washington Post and here's his
personal account Russia and the Russians
by the way in this morning's post and
one of the things Time magazine drew
attention to was the Style section
here's one of those famous big pictures
you can't get much bigger than that of
mrs. Carter and two stories by stereo
booth Conroy both dateline planes
talking about her lifestyle and her new
book and her says she's anxious to get
back out and speak her mind
Moisture baya New York good morning I
wonder if you can tell me a little bit
about the Soviet monetary system
first of all do they have any banks
secondly can citizens obtain loans and
if they can what is the interest rate
charged on these loans in the Soviet
Union I wonder if you could explain that
in terms of the American dollar Thank
You caller good question sure the yeah
the Soviet Union is a soft currency
country the it's the ruble does not
trade officially except in a few places
in perhaps in Vienna and in Geneva but
it does not trade worldwide you can't
convert it it has no value outside its
own borders and that is because the
Soviet economy does not produce
manufactured goods against which you
have any value the trade freely in the
world against which you can peg a peg
the ruble so it's a it is a closed Manas
monetary system does not participate in
a direct way in the great in the hard
currency affairs of the world Soviets
earn a great just as an aside they earn
a great deal of hard currency from oil
exports and from export of raw materials
such as gold and and diamonds and other
precious metals and stones inside the
country the ruble in effect also has no
value but it has little value because
what is important to Soviet citizens as
we discovered there was not so much what
income was income levels are about 180
rubles a month for an average industrial
worker and that would translate if there
were an official exchange rate outside
the country that were translated about
to about 225 to 250 dollars a month but
that 180 rubles is not as important as
what's known as Blatt pull who your
connections are so that you can get in
the the back door or the side door of
the of the of the meat store and get
your cuts of meat through the you know
through connections through the back so
you don't have to stand in line and
maybe get nothing in the front there are
banks they are there their savings banks
and savings interest is about 3% I think
and it's compounded annually there's an
enormous amount of money of rubles saved
by by Soviet citizens in the country
I think economists here call it buried
inflation it just as money that is not
directly in circulation the reason is is
that there's frequently is simply
nothing to spend it on and we saw a
peculiar phenomenon and examples of that
for example when the state in the late
70s doubled the price of gold jewelry as
suddenly states doors which sold gold
jewelry which hadn't had nothing on
their shelves for years suddenly the
shelves were full of gold jewelry why
was the jewelry out well because they've
been sitting on it because they wanted
to wait until the prices went up as soon
as the prices went up and the stuff was
available endless lines formed and
people had all the money they needed to
buy the stuff because they were simply
waiting to spend you know for the one
thing and the two things that they
wanted and since it's a it's an economy
of tremendous deficit there is that kind
of phenomenon of buried inflation there
are no checking accounts as such
everything is done on a cash basis and
people yes a loan question people can
make loans they can get loans from their
from their factories or their
Institute's at a low level you'd be
interested to know that over the past
twenty five years people have a begun to
acquire in a very real way have begun to
acquire personal wealth there are now
cooperative apartment houses in Moscow
and in other major cities you can make a
down payment of five thousand roubles
and swing the rest of the cost of a
cooperative apartment and have ownership
of it and then you can pass that
ownership on through a will to to your
heirs and assigns and and goods and
chattels like that are people are
acquiring that thing that those kinds of
goods it isn't in the at the level which
they want it though and the things that
they do want for example Western genes
you know the standard Western tourists
says can I sell my genes well no it's an
illegal transaction you cannot trade you
know you can't trade hard currency and
rules inside the country legally and
you're not supposed to speculate in sort
of goods and the Western items but
people do sell Western genes for two
hundred three hundred rubles a pair
that's the equivalent
in hard currency terms of four or five
hundred dollars for a pair of jeans that
is an example of buried inflation
Williamstown Massachusetts John with
Kevin close to the Washington Post go
ahead please Matt where's Williamstown
I'm not Boston no no no it's a far with
northwest corner of the state I can look
out and see format in New York
Oh wonderful and what do you read there
in the way of a newspaper the Berkshire
Eagle it's published in Pittsfield which
is a little is it a morning paper yes
you have it there this morning
yes I'm step outside the door so I don't
get feedback my telephone too far away
to turn down the story Reagan going to
China's on the fourth page first page
it's not it's not really covered heavily
on the front pages here either
although the earthquake in California
there's quite a bit of space here you
read any other papers on a daily basis
no you know questions were yes yes I was
most interested in his children going to
school in the Russian schools and I was
wondering their ages in how it affected
them because there must have to be a lot
of communist propaganda in the schools
in order to bring the children up that
way I was wondering how they were
affected thank you for the call nice to
hear from you our children when we went
to Moscow in 1977 we have a daughter and
two two boys two sons and they were
respectively nine eight and four and a
half the older two agreed with us that
they ought to try Soviet public school
they had been in the public schools in
Washington DC and they were sort of
ready for a change and a challenge and
we they were tested we went over for
interviews at Moscow school number five
which happened to be physically located
right across the street from his broad
Boulevard
from in front of the compound where we
were where we lived in a foreign
compound found roof for iners lived
there our kids went across the street to
school was wonderful was the first time
that we had no carpool and we liked that
very much Soviet schools are modeled on
European schools they're very
pedagogical and authoritarian and
they're wonderful places if you're if
you can do it and if you get interested
they're wonderful places to learn such
things as mastery of skills like
handwriting of grammar of mathematics
schools run six days a week and the
curriculum is a ten year curriculum from
age seven to seventeen children wear
uniforms and there is a kind of
old-fashioned real old-world decorum in
in the classroom that persists despite
you know spitball throwing in the usual
hijinks of any kids
when a teacher asks a question and the
student answers that student stands up
and there's that and the teacher if the
teacher likes the question teacher
instantly says a good answer if it's
wrong it's a tremendous it's a block up
or sit down very straight and and
authoritarian a lot easier for you to
discipline at home a lot easier in the
lower grades because our children didn't
speak Russian when they were when they
went to school there were each put back
two grades and so they were older
children amongst substantially younger
kids they made up that that loss over
the four years that we were there and
they then reemerged at their own at
their own grade level but because they
were older kids the teachers
automatically kind of used them to help
you know sort of as class leaders our
kids did very well in the in in those in
that situation the political aspects of
life in a in in this public school were
really that rather innocent in a strange
sort of way I mean there are a lot of
pictures of Lenin around on the
no on the walls and the blackboard and
so forth and there's a lot of sort of
Lennon G linen review of linen Buju
sheets linen then it lived Lennon lives
lemon will live he's kind of wrote
mindless sort of singsong praises to our
kids it had no meaning at all and it
really didn't impact on them and because
they had been in American public schools
and because of the nature of the work
that I was doing there which they were
very much involved in they were really
able to compare the two systems and the
political side of things and they they
quickly understood that for example
world history was taught as though all
of this is a simplification but it's
it's not inaccurate that all of human
history
was aimed at one event the great October
Revolution 1917 and I mean that kind of
that method of teaching history of
looking at the world I mean they saw the
differences and and so the the politics
of it really didn't take there was one
sort of not very effective a political
information class that occurred once or
twice a week in the in the upper grades
our children were not allowed to be
young pioneers which is a sort of Soviet
version of the Boy Scouts and Girl
Scouts in part because they to do so
they would have had to take a pledge
pledging allegiance to the cop SS the
Communist Party of the Soviet Union we
didn't want them to do that they didn't
want to do that and therefore the
directors of the school didn't want our
kids in there young pioneer cadre we
have a seattle caller standing by thank
you for your patience you're on with
kevin close author of this book yes
would like to preface with the statement
that if you compare where the russian
average person was in 1917 to where they
are today i don't know that there's very
many countries in the world that those
people have progressed any further now
could your guests equate our come out
with some
kind of equation as compared to the
socialist government's major socialist
governments as far as health services
education unemployment those kinds of
things as compared to the other
totalitarian governments of the world
which are right-wing totalitarian
military government all right let me
interrupt just a second ask if you have
the Seattle PI there this morning uh yes
I do
could you tell us do they cover the
president's trip what are they covering
up they cover both the president's trip
and the Soviets escalation the war in
Afghanistan now I don't think anybody
can defend the use of force to subjugate
what is evidently a free and resisting
people that's not what I'm looking at
what I'm looking at is we support
right-wing totalitarian governments and
they from my point of view and I'm a
fair student of history have a far worst
history our our course record of
supplying education health needs housing
employment then left-wing totalitarian
government all right thank you for the
call good question a good question I
would agree with you that that's
probably a few people in the in the
world in the 20th century progressed as
far as the as the Soviet peoples have
under under Soviet power that country
was was a backward illiterate peasant
country and is now a literate developing
and developed industrial state with all
that conveys about rise and material
standards of well-being and
I think that was what in large part what
the revolution was intended to be about
other things happened along the way
Stalinist terror being a principal
factor of life even today in the Soviet
Union
millions of people went into the camps
there was tremendous I mean that the
spread of terror and the impact of that
psychologically on on Soviet citizens
today is still felt Stalin only died 31
years ago and as people say in my book
you know when the knock comes on the
door at 3:00 in the morning we don't
think it's the it's the NKVD coming to
take us off to camp but there is this
kind of you know a blink there there is
a there's a sense of fear and
apprehension which exists in the country
and as part of the psychology of life in
that country there is no way that you
know that we can justify that any any of
us should it seems to me justify the
existence of a totalitarian police state
whether it be right-wing or left-wing is
there a difference in my view there
isn't it there is really not a
difference I mean when it comes to the
point of essentially of a police
invasion of an individual's right to to
live to express his rights to have
common human freedoms such as the
freedom to emigrate from this country
which Soviet citizens do not have I mean
when those things are up for grabs then
you really can't call it right or left
and that of course is one of the great
quarrels about what you know what is
this what is the Soviet Union today is
it a left-wing totalitarian government
have you seen the Robin Williams movie
Moscow on the Hudson I haven't had a
chance to see it I very much want to it
was a lot of fun by just finished to
know whether you think it was honest and
that I'm sorry you haven't seen maybe
some of our audiences saying I know
there's one of the one of the supporting
actors one of the Soviet actors we knew
in Moscow who emigrated and it was a
friend there and I very much want to see
it for that for that reason alone I
think he plays a KGB man chasing
Williams I just want to get back to the
to the right-wing question I think that
you know right-wing totalitarian
governments have terrible records in
such things as as public health
education and so forth and and it is a
question as to what our foreign policy
is in fact composed of when we align
ourselves with those kinds of
Byron Township New Jersey good morning
morning Brian how are you why what do
you read me three of them the New York
Times of the North Star Ledger and the
County newspaper and the best paper in
the United States Washington Post weekly
was that finally God and I think it's
good because it covers a lot of national
issues and international issues far
better than the New York Times does Noel
Epstein on money yeah I saw that I'm
home this week from school and I was
able to see it I just couldn't get
through to talk to him I just wanted to
say that to him I'm sorry that Kevin
will be glad to pass it on there oh yeah
standing newspaper it's once a week but
it it's just great when I'm in
Washington I'd like it because my little
daughter gets the cartoons and my wife
gets Style section I just the stuff that
I want which the New York Times does
stuff and do I want to test mr. clothes
an important question at least for me
naive in the sense if I was the graduate
student in Moscow or let's say it's a
local citizen would I have any impact on
what the local governments there does or
do they simply come down with mandates
and everybody has to live with them well
of course there are you know there are
councils life councils in apartment
buildings and things like that but
basically you would not have the kind of
thing that you're thinking of you would
not have impact on the way the local
community ran itself beyond that if you
were a graduate student no matter what
Syria what course of studies you were
engaged in no matter what your major was
about a quarter of it would be would be
devoted to Marxist Leninist philosophy
economics and party matters if you were
studying for example to be a medical
doctor a quarter of your curriculum is
spent in essentially put political
courses that have no relationship to the
you know to the health and well-being of
a patient
those are aspects of of life which have
an impact on how you live by the way as
we said earlier we're going to talk
tomorrow first of all we have a very
interesting guest at 9:00 Charlene
Williams who is a black reporter with
WTOP AM radio here in town the past
president of the National Society of
black journalists not talk about this
whole issue that we have spent so much
time here talking about the Farrakhan
and Jesse Jackson issue but also then
we're going to a special hour from 10:00
to 11:00 house
an 11 that's East Coast time and we're
gonna talk about this story and the Time
magazine this week and I'd like to ask
you to go out and buy a time magazine if
you're interested in this and we'll talk
a lot about what Time magazine says are
the best 10 best US dailies flip the
page here so you can see over here's
someone we spent a lot of time with out
in Des Moines Michael Gartner and here's
William Thomas is the editor of Los
Angeles Times and it goes on over here
three more editors it may be familiar to
you
Heath Merriweather of the Miami Herald
we spent time down there the New York
Times am Rosenthal and Eugene Roberts
Philadelphia Inquirer that was the first
paper that we did our day in the life
series on so we've you know if you
follow us you have a lot of insight into
these papers and if you if you live in
those communities you read them all the
time you have a even better insight so
we thought it'd be fun to talk about
that tomorrow special hour from 10:00 to
11:00 or from 7:00 to 8:00 if you live
in Los Angeles or Santa Barbara Denver
Colorado good morning 29 people have
been murdered in the Dominican Republic
and this story has been buried in the
press barely mention of it of course the
Dominican Republic is government the US
props up we invaded and put this
government in and you know if if for
example the if that were going on in
Poland this would be a front-page story
for weeks and weeks and weeks and eight
years we would hear about this but
because it happened to me the US sphere
of influence it's barely mention you
until unless the were an out-and-out
revolution like in El Salvador if there
were goon squads in Cuba doing what
they're doing in El Salvador this would
be in the front page every day but you
know because it's a government that the
US has an interesting propping up you
know it's barely it's it's barely
mentioning that only because it's a
full-scale revolution the other point is
about the Soviet Union I've had a number
of the books written by press people who
come out of the Soviet Union and they
usually met
the Soviet Union by our standards what
you can get what you can buy how much
you can about how many pairs of jeans
you got and so forth what I want to know
is what my wife's be safe on the streets
of the Soviet Union she's not safe in
this country with my sensibilities and
my sense of purpose be assaulted by
saying men sleeping on the great in
downtown Denver or downtown Philadelphia
what Mathurin law has been unemployed
for two-and-a-half years in this country
and it is making it is breaking his
spirit would that happen in the Soviet
Union let's begin to examine the Soviet
Union from a different perspective than
what you can buy and what you can get
that's what I would let me ask you
caller you saw those The Wall Street
Journal the New York Times and USA Today
all have the Dominican Republic story in
there is it n the Denver Post or the
rock you might media but where did they
where did they put this story this is it
would it be rammed down the people's
throats like in Poland in the Polish
crisis not 20 people were killed in the
entire in the entire crisis but this
happens in one day in the Philippines it
happens routinely where the army goes in
and and okay okay
thank you very much Denver you made your
point mr. Clow's sure several things I
agree with you I don't think we should
we should measure the Soviet Union by
what you can get and what you can spend
and and my book doesn't do it I don't
think a lot of Western correspondents
are preoccupied with those questions
Americans do raise those questions
because the Soviet Union as you well
know proposes itself as you know the
world's greatest power where freedoms
exist in a profusion unknown elsewhere
in the world and where people are
perfectly happy where where the people
are in fact are so happy that party and
party and people are one that there is a
unanimity of views so questions do come
up about such things as you know can
they get meat in the stores etc but I
agree they shouldn't you know we
shouldn't
dwell on those things and be preoccupied
with those kinds of material questions
but they do arise I think that the what
I've tried to do in this book is to tell
the story of life in the Soviet Union as
people themselves know it there is
there's a tremendous amount of street
crime and other kinds of crime in the
Soviet Union you won't find it reported
in the Soviet press because like planes
that never crash
crime doesn't exist either and so that's
a kind of a problem with reality there
and it makes a real problem for people's
sense of safety in a place like Moscow
since they know there is crime but they
know they it's never going to be
reported to them in an accurate way
there was a there was a mass murderer on
the loose in northern northern part of
Moscow several years ago and the police
simply weren't reporting it to the to
the populace but they're coming around
asking people did you see so and so have
you seen so and so without ever
explaining why they wanted to know that
has a tremendous effect on how people
you know they're afraid to go out and
broad daylight and those kinds of
circumstances since they can't get the
truth either from the television or any
other place by the way week after next
the American Society of newspaper
editors meets here in Washington over
the shirt in Washington hotel and we're
gonna be camped out there for about
three days some of it you'll see live
you'll meet a lot of people that we're
talking about here editors and reporters
and also see some of the very
interesting sessions that they've set up
one that I remember is that I think
Norman
Pearlstein is moderating a panel about
the the problem that The Wall Street
Journal had with their hurt on the
street reporter a fellow by the name of
either Wynans or Winans we'll find out
what the correct pronunciation is when
it gets here might point out that today
is our last day of our anniversary
contest the 500 words or less we asked
you to write about why you watch this
network give us some insight into what
what this network does for you the the
kind of thing the special kind of things
that you may have learned and that's the
kind of thing we're looking for and 500
words or less it has to be postmarked by
midnight this evening
and it can be received in here and has
to be received in here by April the 30th
so you have some days for that mail to
travel that's the last day to day for
our contest i watch c-span because
celebrating our fifth anniversary for
Kevin close author of Russians Russia
and the Russians we go now to Marietta
Georgia good morning
Brian good morning mr. close morning
this is your nervous old man from
Marietta Brian nervous one he excuse me
one I have the newspaper of the
Constitution this morning oh good and
two I didn't know if you wanted to
comment today or tomorrow and why it
didn't make the 10 best papers well I'm
gonna get through tomorrow so you might
as well make it today that's right
that's correct a number one it's one of
the worst newspapers in the country
just a quick two liner on why
okay well it's terribly liberal I think
the only once and a great well that'll
be on the op-ed page there'll be a
kilpatrick of somebody writing but most
of it is Mary McCrory and people such as
of her ilk you ever read the journal oh
yes every night no I saw you once before
but bill you can't remember all this but
I read four papers a day what about the
front pages the Constitution's home
right there's a darn good picture of
Reagan which eerily looks like what I
think Kennedy would have looked like had
he lived a lot longer and I did like
that particular Kennedy not not
followers but anyway mister close you've
definitely saw one more copy of your
book if that helps you I'm pleased to
hear that I think you struck a couple of
nerves one in Berkeley and one I think
in Colorado the man who used the word
boudoir which is a minute years than
once a fascist the Boothroyd you know
where he's coming from
finally Brian
shame on you for not knowing where
Williamstown mass is but I just wanted
to go enjoy the program and especially
the sand don't grocery store in
Manchester
you remember that okay oh of course of
course I work every day practically good
for you thank you finally mr. close you
and your children are children what
school in France and as much as we love
France why I don't think we would want
to live there would you want to live
with your family for the rest of your
life and great question thanks a lot
Maria certainly not but we have many
friends there and my wife and our oldest
just for back in Moscow had visas and
we're in for 11 days seeing friends and
we very much hope that that we can
continue to get visas from the Soviet
government and be able to maintain
normal human contacts with people who
are very near and dear to us and who
remain behind and because of the closed
borders of the Soviet Union cannot have
any possibility of ever coming to visit
us
Washington Post reporter Bob Kaiser New
York Times Rich Smith David shipler and
you have all written books and a lot of
other books been written about Russia
and should we say that there's a lot of
uncomplimentary things said in all those
books about the society what are the
Russians think they let you in you come
over and report you stay there for years
and you come out and you say hey this
ain't such a sweet place to go you know
there's a great tradition in American
journalism of dealing with conflict in a
society and of in effect reporting you
know reporting the troubles of a society
because that's one of the ways we
measure whether society is delivering on
its promises to its own people and in
this book where there are lots of heroes
and heroines who are strong people
courageous people who have stood up to a
crushing weight of a regime which is not
interested in people expressing their
individual rights I mean that is a way
of looking at the promises which are
made by that society and whether it
delivers and the nature delivers on
those promises and I mean that seems to
me to be in a in a great and broad and
long tradition of American journalism I
guess for the last hour has been Kevin
close he is the author of Russia and the
Russians available in your bookstores he
is currently the bureau chief of the
Washington Post in Chicago and we want
to thank him very much for being with us
this morning